Speaker 1: Let's stay with presidential politics,
the 2024 race. Donald Trump has been receiving a
little bit of criticism from different circles
about the fact that he doesn't really have any
policy prescriptions for 2024. He rolled on to
the scene in 2015, rolled down his escalator and
came out and called Mexicans rapists. They're
not sending their best. They're sending their
worst rapists and the drugs and the and I assume
some of them are good people, you'll remember.
And then it was Muslim bans and all of
the rest. Now. Where do you go from there?
It seems because Ron DeSantis, again, it seems
to be the chief opponent that we will see.
It seems that Donald Trump is going to try to out
DeSantis, Ron DeSantis out bigot, Ron DeSantis out
homophobe Ron DeSantis. He is going to try to
anti-trans bigots off the charts. And this is
one of the first policy prescriptions that Donald
Trump all along his wall, except now he wants to
oppress a marginalized population in the United
States. Here's Donald Trump talking about what
he wants to do with education and trans rights.
Speaker 2: As part of a new credentialing body
for teachers. We will promote positive
education about the nuclear family,
the roles of mothers and fathers, and
celebrating rather than erasing the
things that make men and women different and
unique. I will ask Congress to pass a bill
establishing that the only gender's recognized
by the United States government are male and
female, and they are assigned at birth.
Speaker 1: This is damaging rhetoric. It's
obviously goofy coming out of the mouth of this
punkin head, but this is dangerous. The trans
population in the United States and likely the
world possesses some of the highest suicide rates.
Among any group. This is hateful. This is
damaging. This is harmful. And for Donald
Trump to tout education about the nuclear
family. What's next for Donald Trump? Well,
we're going to my new policy prescription is to
teach people to have sex with porn stars and then
pay them off with $130,000. Cheat on all my wives.
This is what you have to do to be a good Christian
man in America. And we're going to sign a bill to
make it so. This is hypocrisy. This is hate. This
is xenophobia. And really, it boils down to where
does Donald Trump go from here? He's already he's
playing the greatest hits. We've seen the greatest
hits in 2016. He tried to replace some of that in
2020. He created new things to whine and complain
about and fearmonger about in 2020. So where does
he go from here? He's going to have to level up.
He's going to have to ramp up the hatred and the
bigotry and the xenophobia and the racism. He's
going to have to do that to to reconnect to the
base, to inflame their passions. This is what he's
going to have to do. And listen, I don't know.
I fear for the country. I fear for marginalized
groups. Look, I'm going to be okay.
I'm a white guy in America. I could I could
feel up and down the street and still do. Okay.
But it's marginalized groups. It's those desperate
people coming from other countries trying to make
a better life for themselves and escape brutality
in their home countries that are going to suffer.
It's the LGBTQ community in this country that will
suffer. It is a rogue Magnus Supreme Court that
has been appointed by Donald Trump that's going to
enact bring to fruition this type of oppression.
We need to to brace ourselves for the fight
ahead. We need to enlist those around us who
have compassion and empathy for humankind to
get to the polls. Your family, your neighbors,
your friends, your coworkers, your acquaintances.
These conversations, while uncomfortable,
need to be talked about because you may know a
Republican. You may think to yourself that he's
a decent person. He yeah, he votes Republican,
but he doesn't. He doesn't care if if gay people
get married. But if that person, this good
and decent person, votes for someone who
then oppresses with their legislation, who then
votes and enacts policy that does oppress people,
how is that good and decent person any better
than what they enacted through their votes?
And I think this is the way we need to talk
about this going forward into 2024, because we've
witnessed from a distance. Fortunately for me, but
some not from a distance. Millions of people live
in Florida. They've witnessed Ron DeSantis
and the things he's been able to accomplish
with his Republican majority. They're trying
to turn America in to Florida. And that is a
terrifying proposition. So I hope that you become
as passionate as I feel about this and move into
2024 to combat this nonsense, because as scary as
it was in 2016 and as scary as it could have been.
After the 2020 election, it's going
to get worse. I hope you're in for it.